as NASA's Dart spacecraft honed in on
the asteroid dimorphos 11 million
kilometers from Earth dark's creators
held their breath and crossed their
fingers
impact but it took another two weeks to
learn whether Dart had indeed hit its
Target on Tuesday NASA officials
announced the good news for the first
time ever
Humanity has changed the orbit of a
planetary body of a planetary object
first time ever
dart's collision with the asteroid
shortened its orbit around another
asteroid by 32 minutes far more than the
73 seconds predicted NASA's
administrator says this kind of cosmic
shove could protect the earth and its
inhabitants from the kinds of meteors
that wiped out the dinosaurs 65 million
years ago now this is a watershed moment
for planetary defense
and a watershed moment for Humanity
and that's why it was fitting that Dart
was an international endeavor
science
benefits Humanity
this is a unifying mission
building spacecraft that can intercept
asteroids won't offer enough protection
scientists say they need better ways of
figuring out which space objects might
be a threat in the first place the more
time we have for that little nudge in
the in the change in that orbital period
to really make a change the better off
We Are Scientists say they have lots of
data to review and they'll use those
insights to help them knock asteroids
out of Earth's way Rosalind Jordan Al
Jazeera